Transcription: RAGOU GOVARDANANE
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
Hello everyone.
Bonjour à tous.
Alors ça, c’est une carte de crédit.
En plastique.
C’est l’équivalent des 5 grammes de
plastique qu’on ingère chaque semaine.
Imaginez ce que ça peut donner
sur toute une vie.
Ce plastique, mais il vient d’où ?
Il vient des produits en plastique recyclé
ou en plastique qu’on consomme
et qu’on produit chaque jour.
Lorsqu’on met bout à bout
tous les événements climatiques
catastrophiques de cet été :
les incendies de forêt en Turquie,
en Grèce ou dans le sud de la France,
les inondations sans précédent
en Belgique, en Chine, à New York,
la canicule au Canada...
on se dit qu’on en est presque dans un
film de superproduction apocalyptique.
Mais malheureusement,
ce n’est pas un film.
C'est bien la triste réalité qui est
devenue aujourd'hui impossible à ignorer.
Le dernier rapport du GIEC
nous confirme encore les pires prévisions
mais la bonne nouvelle,
c’est qu’il est encore temps d’agir.
Il est encore temps
de repenser nos actions,
d’arrêter avec ce déni, ce désintérêt,
la sidération.
On peut encore empêcher
ces sombres prévisions.
L’être humain est capable de tant,
même de l’impossible.
De multiples problèmes contribuent
au changement climatique.
On le sait tous.
Mais il y en a un, très simple,
pour lequel chacun de nous,
dans cette salle,
on peut faire quelque chose dès demain,
dès maintenant :
la pollution plastique.
Vous me direz “Mais quel est le lien
entre le changement climatique
et la pollution plastique ?”
Eh bien, c’est très simple.
Les débris qui sont présents
par millions dans l’environnement
et qui enlaidissent le paysage,
se fragmentent en de minuscules fragments
de moins de 5 millimètres
sous l’effet des rayons ultraviolets
du soleil et de l’oxydation.
On appelle ça les microplastiques.
Une étude, très intéressante,
publiée aux États-Unis en août 2018,
a mis évidence pour la toute première fois
que la dégradation et la décomposition
de ces déchets plastiques
libèrent des gaz à effet de serre.
Ce qui veut dire concrètement
que la pollution plastique contribue
inévitablement
au réchauffement climatique.
Vous voyez, c’est assez simple,
et il est important de le comprendre.
Il est important de le réaliser,
car aujourd’hui, l’océan détient,
à lui seul, 80% des déchets plastiques
de la planète.
Donc imaginez le niveau de gaz
à effet de serre que cela peut donner.
Les chercheurs ont fait des tests,
sur tous les types de produits,
comme par exemple les bouteilles, les sacs
les emballages, les produits industriels
Et ils sont arrivés à la conclusion
que le polyéthylène était
l’émetteur le plus prolifique.
Le polyéthylène, ou on l’appelle PE aussi,
est l’un des plastiques
les plus répandus dans le monde.
Il sert à fabriquer des objets moulés,
souvent jetables.
On l’utilise notamment
pour des bouteilles d’eau.
La bonne nouvelle, c’est que si on prend
des mesures audacieuses maintenant
pour réduire la pollution plastique
et notre consommation,
nous réduirons notre empreinte carbone
et l’empreinte carbone
des gaz à effet de serre
produits par ces déchets plastiques.
La pollution plastique est
aujourd’hui devenue
l’un des plus grands fléaux
de notre temps.
Ce n'est pas moi qui le dis, c'est l'ONU.
Mais revenons un instant
sur le point fondamental.
Le plastique, au fond, c’est quoi ?
C’est un matériau fantastique,
qui a été inventé par l’homme, pour durer.
Pour durer très longtemps,
beaucoup plus longtemps
que chacun de nous.
Il peut être presque tout ce qu’on veut.
Solide, souple, résistant,
ou même malléable à la chaleur.
Beaucoup pensent que
c’est  l’une des inventions
les plus extraordinaires de l’humain.
Du coup, nous l’avons introduit
dans toutes les industries,
dans tous les produits autour de nous,
et nous en produisons
dans des quantités inimaginables.
Le plastique est aujourd'hui
omniprésent dans nos vies.
Il y en a partout.
Nous vivons dans une époque
où l’on touche plus de plastique
que les gens qu’on aime.
Le plastique ne disparaît jamais,
même lorsqu'il se dégrade.
L'homme redevient poussière, mais pas lui.
Il se transforme en petites particules et
reste pour des siècles dans l'atmosphère,
dans l'océan, dans le sol.
Certains disent que nous sommes
à l’ère numérique.
Moi, je dis que nous sommes
à l’ère du plastique.
Les générations futures
qui étudieront notre époque
trouveront des plastiques fossiles,
qu’ils exposeront
dans des musées d’archéologie
pour illustrer notre époque.
C’est un peu triste, non ?
On en a d’ailleurs déjà trouvé,
de ces plastiques fossiles.
C’est Charles Moore qui a découvert,
par hasard, en 2006, cette nouvelle pierre
faite de plastique et d’éléments naturels.
Avec ses collègues,
ils les ont appelées le “plastiglomerate”.
Depuis, on en découvre des millions.
Et ce n’est que le début.
De 15 millions de tonnes en 1960,
la production du plastique a grimpé
à un rythme exponentiel
pour s’établir à un peu plus de
300 millions de tonnes aujourd’hui,
dont environ 40% sont destinées
uniquement aux emballages.
Alors, dans les chiffres,
on nous dit que nous sommes passés
de 367 millions de tonnes
de plastique en 2020
contre 368 millions en 2019,
et qu’un tel recul
dans la production de ce matériau
n’était pas arrivé depuis 1973.
Mais voilà , ce recul,
on ne le doit malheureusement pas
à l’éveil mondial de l’industrie.
On le doit à la pandémie du coronavirus
et au confinement.
C’est la troisième baisse mondiale
depuis l’après-guerre.
Il y a donc eu 1973,
au moment du premier choc pétrolier.
Puis en 2008,
lors de la crise des subprimes.
Et maintenant 2020,
avec la crise du coronavirus.
Et cela nous dit
quelque chose de très simple :
c’est qu’il est possible
de réduire cette production.
Il est possible de réduire
notre consommation de plastique
et donc de réduire les déchets
qui finiront dans l’environnement.
Et cela tombe bien, parce qu’il est urgent
de le faire... maintenant.
L’accumulation des déchets
dans l’environnement et dans l’océan
est d’une ampleur sans précédent.
Et il n’est pas besoin de se rendre
à l’autre bout de la planète
pour s’en rendre compte.
Si on n’agit pas concrètement maintenant,
pas en 2030, pas en 2040, mais maintenant,
la pollution plastique étouffera l’océan,
et l’humain avec.
Notre planète bleue est tout simplement
emballée dans du plastique.
Un peu comme
l’Arc de Triomphe actuellement.
Ce problème, ce n'est pas celui
de tel ou tel pays.
Ce problème, c’est le nôtre,
à tous, partout dans le monde,
quels que soient notre couleur,
notre genre, nos croyances,
nos goûts et nos différences.
Car c’est la vie sur Terre
qui est menacée.
On sait aujourd’hui,
que la pollution plastique,
c’est une question de pollution de l’air.
Donc, même si tous les scientifiques
ignorent encore exactement
toutes les maladies que
cette catastrophe sanitaire va produire,
on sait.
Oui, on sait qu’aujourd’hui,
cela provoque de l’asthme,
le cancer et l’infertilité.
Et je pense que vous serez
d’accord avec moi :
que nous n’avons pas besoin
d’en savoir plus.
Nous n’avons pas besoin d’avoir encore
une étude supplémentaire, pour nous dire
et nous confirmer tout ça, pour agir.
Vous avez certainement entendu parler
du recyclage du plastique.
On vous a certainement dit que
le plastique recyclé, c’est LA solution
pour régler ce problème.
Et peut être que vous y croyez.
Au début, comme vous, j’y ai cru.
J’ai trouvé cela formidable.
Mais voilà, c’est totalement faux.
Le plastique ne se recycle pas à l'infini,
comme le verre, l'aluminium ou le papier.
Le pire, c’est qu’il crée
tout au long de son cycle de vie
des microplastiques ou nanoplastiques.
Ces fameux microplastiques qu'on respire,
qu'on mange, proviennent de ces produits
en plastique ou plastique recyclé
que nous produisons,
utilisons encore et encore et encore.
Nous en sommes devenus
tout simplement accros.
Et c’est tout particulièrement le cas
pour ma génération et la vôtre incluse.
Nous avons du mal à nous séparer de
certains objets en plastique
parce qu’ils nous sont nostalgiques.
Ils sont liés à des traditions familiales.
Ils nous ont accompagnés
dans notre enfance.
On a un rapport de dépendance
à certains objets plastiques.
Comme, par exemple,
les ballons pour les anniversaires,
les déguisements d’Halloween,
les poupées Barbie,
les figurines Marvel, les Lego,
les sapins de Noël, artificiels bien sûr,
le frisbee, les scoubidous,
le Rubik’s cube, les ballons de foot,
tous ces objets en plastique,
c’est dur d’en faire le deuil.
Alors on continue, on continue,
on transmet cette addiction à nos enfants.
La boucle, elle doit s'arrêter avec vous.
L’idée, ce n’est pas de supprimer tout ça,
mais de le repenser.
Il est temps qu’on repense nos traditions,
nos fêtes, nos amusements
pour une vie sans plastique.
Nous devons garder
en ligne de mire l’essentiel :
notre rôle dans l’écosystème.
Ce rôle n’est pas celui de dominer
ou de se croire au-dessus de la nature.
Nous connaissons mille fois plus
de choses que nos ancêtres.
Nous avons beaucoup plus facilement
accès à la connaissance.
Nous pouvons utiliser cette intelligence
pour créer un monde
en harmonie avec la nature,
pour l’aider à se régénérer,
pour réparer les erreurs du passé.
Lorsqu’il y a eu le premier confinement,
j’ai lu beaucoup d’articles
qui venaient de tout le monde entier,
disant que la Terre respirait enfin,
que l’air était pur,
qu’on voyait enfin
pour la première fois depuis 30 ans
les sommets de l’Himalaya en Inde.
Certains affirmaient même
n’avoir jamais assisté à un tel spectacle
de leur vivant.
Pour ma part, ces bonnes nouvelles,
elles m’ont rendue triste.
Je me suis dit
« Mais comment est-il possible
qu’il faille enfermer,
tous les humains chez eux,
pour que la nature puisse enfin
revivre et respirer ? »
C’était comme si nous, les humains,
étions les intrus de cet écosystème,
les intrus sur cette planète.
Pourtant, nous ne sommes pas des intrus.
Nous faisons tout autant partie
des êtres vivants de cette planète.
Nous y avons vu le jour,
nous y avons notre place.
Nous avons simplement oublié
que nous faisions partie d’un tout,
que nous sommes connectés à la nature,
que nous faisons qu’un avec la planète.
Sans océans, il n’y a pas de vie.
Sans océans, il n’y a pas d’oxygène.
Sans cette planète bleue, nous aurons
vraiment du mal à vivre sur cette planète.
On me demande souvent
« Comment peut-on agir concrètement
contre la pollution plastique ? »
La solution, c’est avant tout de limiter
les futures pollutions plastiques.
Et pour cela, il faut s’informer.
S’informer, c’est d’abord comprendre que
réintroduire le plastique dans nos vies,
dans les mains de nos enfants
pour un nouveau cycle,
n’est pas la solution.
Nous n’arrêterons pas
la pollution comme ça.
S’informer, c’est apprendre et comprendre
où se cache le plastique
parce qu’il y a les objets évidents,
bien sûr, qu’on connait tous,
comme la bouteille d’eau,
les sacs en plastique, les pailles...
Et puis, il y a ce qu’on appelle
les plastiques cachés,
mais qui sont non moins présents
dans nos vies :
les chewing-gums, les paillettes,
les rouges à lèvres, les crèmes solaires,
les sachets de thé, les pneus,
le drapé de l’Arc de triomphe.
Enfin, je peux continuer
comme ça toute la journée.
Nous devons repenser
notre mode de consommation.
Et ce n’est pas si compliqué.
Les solutions, les alternatives,
elles existent déjà.
Et ce ne sont ni des produits
plus contraignants, moins efficaces,
moins esthétiques ou moins à la mode.
Combien de marques existe-t-il déjà
qui proposent des articles désirables
et sans plastique ?
Eh bien, je vais vous le dire :
il y en a beaucoup.
Et il y en a de plus en plus.
Je sais qu’il est difficile
d’imaginer une vie sans plastique,
mais c’est vraiment nécessaire.
Je rêve d’un monde
où j’irai faire du shopping
et que je n’aurai plus besoin de vérifier
si un produit contient ou non du plastique
Car les marques,
les industriels auront fait en sorte
de les bannir de nos rayons.
Nous devons cesser
de vouloir absolument trouver
comment donner une autre vie
aux déchets plastiques.
Pourquoi pensons-nous
que c’est la seule solution ?
Pour agir, nous devons aussi
continuer à ramasser tout le plastique
tant que c’est encore possible.
Alors, je dis bien tant que
c'est encore possible.
Car si on attend trop longtemps,
ces déchets plastiques vont se dégrader
en des morceaux invisibles à l’œil nu.
Et ce n’est pas parce qu’on le voit plus
qu’il n’existe plus.
Mais au lieu de refaire faire un cycle
de nuisance à ce plastique recyclé,
investissons, mettons en place
des structures pour l’éradiquer
ou le valoriser en énergie.
Mais cessons d’en refaire d’autres objets,
d’autres produits, vêtements en plastique
qui redeviendront inévitablement
des déchets plastiques.
Quand vous serez dans la vie active,
en poste dans des industries,
au gouvernement
ou comme jeune entrepreneur·e,
pensez-y et faites circuler l’information.
Au lieu d’investir
des milliards dans le recyclage,
on devrait investir
dans la mise en place des innovations
des solutions qui existent déjà
pour qu’on puisse les utiliser,
massivement, de manière industrielle,
pour lutter contre la pollution plastique.
En 2018, une équipe de chercheurs
a découvert une enzyme,
une bactérie qui serait capable
de détruire naturellement
de fortes quantités de plastique
en un temps record.
En 2019, un jeune Irlandais, âgé de 18 ans
a trouvé le moyen d’utiliser
le liquide magnétique de la NASA,
pour éliminer
les microplastiques nocifs de l’eau.
Vous voyez?
Il y a plein d'espoir dans l'innovation.
Arrêtons de nous faire croire
qu’il n’est pas possible
de faire autrement dès à présent.
Les solutions, elles sont déjà là.
Bon, vous l’avez compris,
le recyclage du plastique,
ce n’est pas vraiment la solution.
L'économie circulaire n'a de sens
que si c'est un cercle vertueux.
Dans le cas contraire, le seul sens,
c'est celui de l'économie.
Aujourd’hui, vous qui êtes
cette nouvelle génération,
vous avez l’avenir entre vos mains.
Et ce ne sont pas que des mots.
Nous sommes à un tournant sans précédent
dans l’histoire de l’humanité
Et vous avez la chance de pouvoir remettre
au centre des innovations à venir,
la nature.
Je suis sûre que dans cette salle,
chacun de vous a la capacité
de changer le monde.
Chaque génération s’imagine être
plus intelligente que celle d’avant,
et plus sage que celle qui vient.
Mais la vérité, c’est que
chaque génération a tendance à oublier
que la nature est pleine de surprises
et pleines d’intelligence.
C’est en devenant
des humains éco-conscients,
qui intègrent l’intelligence de la nature
que vous gagnerez en intelligence,
et que vous changerez le monde
pour le mieux.
Chaque innovation devrait être pensée
avec l’effet papillon qu’elle produit
sur la planète et notre écosystème.
Car si nous détruisons
les ressources de notre planète,
nous créons un monde où il sera
de plus en plus difficile de vivre.
Votre génération,
elle a le pouvoir de faire ça,
de modifier notre manière de consommer,
de voyager, de profiter de la vie.
Beaucoup de choses,
qui nous paraissent normales aujourd’hui,
ne le sont pas du tout
et le seront encore moins dans l’avenir.
Nous devons apprendre à désapprendre.
Il se trouve que
l’évolution a fait de nous
l’être vivant le plus intelligent
de cette planète.
Je pense qu'il y a une raison à cela.
Utilisons le génie humain
pour transformer le monde
et non pour le détruire.
Certains vous diront sans doute,
« c’est impossible ».
Je sais.
Je vais vous dire où je puise
la force de croire en vous,
d’avancer et de continuer chaque jour.
C’est un événement qui m’a marquée
quand j’étais enfant.
Je viens d’une famille de Hongrois,
exilés en France, réfugiés politiques
qui ont dû fuir
du jour au lendemain leur pays
à cause du régime communiste.
J’ai été élevée avec l’idée
que le mur de Berlin ne tomberait jamais.
Et à cette époque là,
le monde entier le pensait.
Puis est venue la nuit du 9 novembre 1989,
et cette nuit-là, le mur est tombé.
C’est un événement
qui a bouleversé le monde entier,
Et c’est un événement
qui a été un exemple très concret pour moi
que tout est toujours possible,
même quand cela paraît impossible
et que le monde entier y croit.
Je souhaiterais terminer
par une citation de Mohammed Ali,
que j’affectionne tout particulièrement.
« Impossible n’est rien qu’une excuse,
avancée par ceux qui trouvent
plus facile de vivre dans le monde
qui leur a été légué
plutôt que de chercher en eux
la force de le changer.
Impossible n’est pas un fait,
c’est une opinion.
Impossible n’est pas une fatalité.
C’est un défi. »
Relevez-le.
Merci.
(applaudissements)